chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Reconnaître le principe de
JoJoyce. Je demande au premier
miministre qu'on puisse poser
cece geste aujourd'hui.
- - Je suis d'accord avec
lele principe de Joyce.
LLà où j'ai un problème,
c'c'est quand on voit une vidéo
dudu député de Jacques Cartier
ququi fait un amalgame
enentre Joyce Echaquan...
ANANDRÉ FORTIN, leader
paparlementaire, Parti libéral,c
- - Je suis outré que le premier
miministre choisisse cette
ququestion-là. Cette question-là
susur le principe de Joyce pour
s's'en prendre à la conduite d'n
dédéputé qui n'a absolument rieà
sese reprocher Monsieur
lele président.
- - C'est reparti pour une autre
jojournée. Monsieur Legault en a
paparlé ce matin. José, Martinet
ChChristian. Je tenais à vous
prprésenter. Cela va être un peu
lolong. C'est un petit film qu'n
vovous a monté. La fameuse
vividéo... est-ce qu'on peut
l'l'avoir? On va montrer cela. n
vava montrer la réaction de
MoMonsieur Legault parce que ce
mamatin l'expliquait qu'il venat
avavant la période de question e
vivisionner la vidéo et c'est pr
çaça qu'il était de mauvaise
huhumeur. C'est pour ça qu'il a
réréagi comme ça. Est-ce que ça
jujustifiait ceci? D'abord, voii
cocomment cela s'est passé.
- - Je ne pouvais pas, comme
prpremier ministre du Québec,
lalaisser insulter les Québécoi.
PaParce que ce que Greg Kelley a
fafait, c'est d'insulter
leles Québécois. Moi, je pense
quque s'il y a quelqu'un qui a
ininstrumentalisé l'anniversaire
dede Madame Echaquan, c'est
GaGabriel Nadeau Dubois
etet Dominique Anglade.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE_
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Hier, c'était le moment
d'd'être solennel par rapport
àà la question de Joyce.
EtEt hier en chambre, ce n'est
papas ce que nous avons vu tout
dudu tout sur cet enjeu-là.
OnOn est allé dans des attaques
papartisanes alors qu'on aurait
papas dues se retrouver là.
- - On n'a pas pesé sur des
pipitons, il y a quelque chose i
mamarche pas. Traiter mon co-
poporteparole de radical parce
ququ'il soulève la question
dudu racisme systémique dont
lala très grande majorité
dedes Québécois reconnaissent
dodont sont victimes les Premiès
NaNations.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Tu as dit à tout le monde,
tutu as dit à tout le monde...
- - Est-ce que vous avez eu
dedes discussions avec Monsieur
KeKelly sur la vidéo en questio,
dedepuis hier?
- - Tu as dit à tout le monde...
IlIl faut se tenir loin des
amamalgames. Je l'ai mentionné
àà plusieurs reprises.
- - Est-ce que vous avez discuté
avavec Monsieur Kelly?
- - Bien sûr que j'ai discuté
avavec Monsieur Kelly, il faut
sese tenir loin des amalgames,
jeje le dis et je le répète.
- - Cela a été un peu plus long
quque d'habitude mais je voulais
totout vous montrer pour que les
gegens comprennent des qu'on
paparle. On parle de vidéo, on
ététait mélangé. On a tout vu.
JoJosé, est-ce qu'il y avait
mamatière à ce choqué comme le
prpremier ministre l'a fait?
- - Oui mais pas cette journée.
DoDonc c'est quand même intriga,
j'j'aimerais savoir qui a donné
cecette vidéo au premier ministe
lele matin du premier anniversae
dudu décès de Joyce Echaquan? Il
meme semble que c'était cela le
susujet hier. Cela devrait être
cocorrigé aujourd'hui. Demain, n
s's'en va vers la première joure
dede la vérité et de la
réréconciliation. C'est un
fefestival d'amalgame de part et
d'd'autre. Non je pense que
MoMonsieur Legault n'a pas eu un
bobon timing. Monsieur Kelly s't
fafait le reflet d'une certaine
mamanière de l'opinion dominante
dadans la communauté Anglo
ququébécoise. Restons dans la
cocommunauté québécoise
ananglophone. C'est ma spéciali.
JeJe connais les discours. Il na
papas vraiment changé. Le proble
avec Monsieur Kelly ce qu'il a
fafait des amalgames, et tout ce
ququ'on entend dans la communaué
AnAnglo québécoise. Ce qui fait
quque pour Madame Anglade, c'est
unun problème politique sérieux.
PaParce que elle a devant elle
coconquit ce qui est divisé sura
ququestion du projet de loi 96 i
vava renforcer la loi 101.
JeJe pense que ça va être comple
popour Madame Anglade dans
l'l'prochaines semaines de jongr
avavec ça.
- - Pourquoi diable Monsieur
LeLegault a visionné ce vidéo qi
dadate de juin. La journée mêmùu
totout le monde s'attendait et e
pepense que j'insiste sur tout e
momonde, que le niveau soit pu
élélever au salon bleu.
- - C'est une vidéo dont on ne
sasait pas trop qui l'a tourné.
MaMais Monsieur Legault
efeffectivement aurait dû s'éler
unun peu pour le premier ministe
a a des devoirs que les autres
n'n'ont pas. Les partis
d'd'opposition posent des
ququestions plus partisanes quea
momoyenne c'est une chose mais e
prpremier ministre lui doit faie
lala part des choses dans son
chchapeau de chef de la CAQ et
chchapeau de premier ministre. l
nene l'a pas fait hier.
AuAujourd'hui il était sur la
dédéfensive sur cet enjeu. Elle
n'n'a pas eu une très bonne
jojournée. Même chose pour Madae
AnAnglade, qui fait un grand éct
susur cet enjeu. Monsieur Legaut
a a assez d'expérience politique
popour être capable de voir une
vividéo le matin et de ne pas sn
seservir le jour même. Elle a ft
vrvraiment un choix calculé quee
s's'en servir.
- - On a parlé hier. Vous disiez
ChChristian que son refus
d'd'accepter le racisme systémie
vovous dites que vous le
cocomprenez. Vous l'avez à
plplusieurs reprises. Sur l'espe
d'd'équation entre cette vidéo i
a a ressorti et le truc, et rese
enencore un malaise. La preuve :
ilil a dû en parler aujourd'hui
- - Un beau gâchis. Je suis
d'd'accord avec Martine. C'est
auaussi le premier ministre
MoMonsieur Legault. C'était quad
mmême la journée de Madame Joyce
EcEchaquan. Je trouve que ça
trtrouve une très belle...
sisi on veut s'assurer que le
raracisme Québec augmente et que
leles préjugés augmentent
cocontinuer à parler de ça.
VoVous connaissez ma position, e
trtrouve que c'est un concept qi
n'n'a pas de sciences ou de
sosociologie se. C'est
ididéologique. Ce n'est pas vrai
quque partout dans le monde il y
avavait moyen de décrocher?
OnOn revient toujours avec ça et
jeje trouve que c'est malsain.
MoMonsieur Legault quand elle dt
nonon à cela, il représente la
mamajorité des Québécois dans la
memesure où on peut généraliser.
LeLes Québécois n'accepteront
jajamais ça. Est-ce qu'on peut
dédécrocher de ça?
- - Vous dîtes que.. l'obsession
vevenait de? Vous dites que les
ququestions de Madame Anglade et
dede Gabriel Nadeau Dubois qui t
dedemandé au premier ministre
d'd'accepter le principe de Joy,
vovous dîtes que c'est eux qui t
101008 sur le fait?
- - Non. La journée de Madame
EcEchaquan. Je trouve qu'il a ue
papartie des élites politiques u
QuQuébec et qui sont obsédés par
çaça. Ils sont déconnectés des
QuQuébécois. Soyons réalistes.
JeJe ne crois pas qu'elle
QuQuébécois n'ont jamais accepté
cecette affaire. Ça vient du
CaCanada anglais qui n'a pas de
leleçons à nous donner. Ils ont
rerepensé aux débats en anglais.
EsEst-ce qu'on a des leçons à
rerecevoir à propos de racisme?
- - Martine. Est-ce que c'était
leles débrouillards?
- - Les partis de l'opposition
ététaient vraiment dans la
papartisane rient. Il y avait la
ququestion du premier ministre.
J'J'ai dit ce que j'avais vu hi.
C'C'est ce matin. L'enjeu de
raracisme systémique va devenir
cocompliqué et ça devient
cocompliliqué pour Madame Anglae
nonotamment à cause de la vidéo
ququ'on a vue. Elle devra apporr
lala définition qu'elle voit ele
coconcernant le racisme
sysystémique. Est-ce que la loi1
fafait parti de ce système-là?
EsEst-ce qu'on est dans ce genre
dedeux définitions? Je vous
rarappelle aussi que Philippe
PhPhilippe Couillard avait eu de
grgros problèmes sur l'enjeu du
elelle lavaient reconnu racisme
IlIl a reculé après l'élection
papartielle. Elle avait dit à ce
momoment qu'on a reçu une taloc.
ElElle avait reculé sur cet enju
paparce que j'avais l'impression
quque le vote francophone lui
glglissait des mains à ce momen.
MaMadame Anglade se retrouve
exexactement dans la même
sisituation et aujourd'hui ellea
eueu un très mauvais point de
prpresse. Alors qu'elle était tt
écécartée entre sa base
ananglophone, vers qui s'est
adadressé Monsieur Kelly, et
l'l'électorat francophone.
- - Cela peut profiter plus à
MoMonsieur Legault de revenir ac
ceces débats.
- - Non. Je pense que si on
rerevient sur le fond des chose,
çaça m'échappe qu'on remet en
ququestion l'existence du racise
sysystémique au Canada envers ls
auautochtones. C'est un phénomèe
ququi est historique et
sosociologique et politique qui
esest amplement documenté par de
nonombreux chercheurs. C'est bin
cecelui-là. Je pense qu'au lieue
paparler au nom de québécois et
l'l'québécois sont plus de 8
mimillions. On ne pense pas tous
lala même chose. Grégory Kelly a
papas insulté l'québécois sinonl
sese serait auto insulté. Il a
ququébécois lui-même. Je pense e
sisi on demandait à la populatin
sisi on pense que le racisme
sysystémique envers les
auautochtones existe, je pense
ququ'il y a beaucoup de québécos
ququi dirait oui. Dire le contre
c'c'est-à-dire que la Terre est
papalte. Ce qui est troublant ds
cecela, c'est parce que certains
pepersonnes dont Monsieur Kelly
fofont des amalgames entre les
prprojets de loi 96 21 racisme
sysystémique. Cela ne donne pasa
pepermission au premier ministre
dede faire la même chose à
l'l'inverse. Est-ce qu'on pourrt
s's'aider et s'attarde à la
ququestion envers les autochton?
CeCe sont les Premières Nations
elelle-même qui demande au
gogouvernement de la reconnaîtr.
JeJe pose une question très sime
: : si le racisme systémique est
unun phénomène documenté à travs
lele Canada, comment peut-on
crcroire que le Québec est la
seseule province qui en serait
exexemptée? C'est absolument
imimpossible. Pourquoi on ne pet
papas le reconnaître et pourquoi
onon ne peut pas avancer avec
cecela? Ce n'est pas une questin
dede toute culpabilisation. C'et
rereconnaître le réel pour qu'on
pupuisse travailler ensemble et
s's'entendre.
- - Arrêtéz Christian. Vous dist
hihier que les autochtones, c'et
vrvrai que...
- - c'est sûr que sur le plan
cacanadien la loi fédérale sur s
InIndiens c'est du racisme d'Ét.
AuAu Québec notre bilan n'est ps
trtrès bon mais il est meilleur
quque le reste du Canada. Je
rereviens sur Monsieur Legault.l
dodoit faire attention. La
tetentation à des mesures. Il et
trtrès, très populaire. On sorte
lala pandémie. Il se présente
cocomme le défenseur de la natin
ququébécoise et ça peut justifi.
MaMais il y a un danger. On l'au
hihier. Il a été trop été emporé
papar l'émotion. Je ne sais pasi
c'c'était authentique ou ci-joit
jejeu. Même si moi je les rappee
jeje trouve que son refus du
raracisme systémique, ça
cocorrespond... je trouve que
l'l'québécois c'est une grosse
ererreur. Même Monsieur Couillad
esest revenu sur sa position à
cacause de ça. Les francophones
veveulent pas de ça.
- - C'était beaucoup plus large
quque les nations autochtones ac
MoMonsieur Couillard. C'était
vrvraiment...
- - peut-être juste pour les
auautochtones...
- - dans ce cas là on parle juse
dede...
- - on est dans une dynamique
popolitique. C'est impossible
dede...
- - je suis au courant. Je suis
popolitologue.
- - José. Conclusion.
CeCela m'amène à une autre
ququestion.
- - Je suis au courant que c'est
unune dynamique politique. Je ss
ananalyste politique. La questin
popour moi c'est de regarder le
fofond des problèmes. Si on
popouvait regarder le problème l
ququ'il est. On peut analyser
auautant qu'on veut mais ce qui
m'm'inquiète c'est d'avoir une
foforce politique qui n'avait ps
rereconnaître le réel et je pene
quque la majorité des Québécois,
papas tous les québécois mais la
mamajorité n'a pas de difficults
àà la reconnaître.
- - Très bien. Je reviens non ps
àà l'amalgame, chacun jugera,
cocomme a dit José dans la
cocommunauté anglophone, il y a
dedes questions qui se posent.
EnEnlever le débat du racisme
sysystémique. Je ne veux pas en
paparler. Est-ce qu'on a le dro,
leles anglophones du Québec onte
drdroit de poser des questions r
lele projet de loi? Vous avez
tétémoigné Christian. A-t-on le
drdroit de poser des questions,e
poposer des questions sur
l'l'utilisation... sans être
acaccusé d'être contre le Québe?
OnOn a l'impression qu'on ne pet
plplus parler.
- - On peut poser des questions.
C'C'est évident. Il faut poser s
ququestions. Ce n'est pas parce
ququ'il y a des gens qui
cocontestent le refus du racisme
sysystémique ou le projet de los
ququi ne sont pas des Québécois.
CeCela va de soi. Il faut surtot
reregarder son calme. Ce sont ds
susujets qui sont facilement
émémotifs. Ils sont polarisant.
C'C'est un beau gâchis hier. Un
trtrès beau gâchis. Parce que ls
gegens ont dérapé. Le premier
miministre avant d'avoir
d'd'exemplarité. Il devait gardr
soson calme.
- - Ce n'est pas la première fo.
MoMonsieur Legault a tendance de
KiKillian opposition, soit la li
sosoit la loi 21 août son projen
a a l'impression t de loi 96,
onon a l'impression que les gens
sosont exclus du Québec.
- - C'est vrai je dirais depuise
dédébut de la session. Depuis le
dédébat en anglais, il en a
vrvraiment fait un coup. Il se
dédéfinit lui-même comme le
dédéfenseur du Québec. Il l'a ft
auau lendemain du débat en
ananglais. Il a rejoué cette cae
etet on sentait quand même que
l'l'élastique C - un peu.
C'C'est passé difficilement. Il
ététait un peu dans les gares et
ququ'il s'est rendu compte qu'il
auaurait dû avoir un peu plus de
hahauteur hier. Il ne voulait ps
s's'excuser. Il s'est placé sur
cecette situation. Il sort souvt
lala carte du : je ne peux pas
lalaisser les québécois se faire
acaccuser de tous les noms.
C'C'est vrai que c'est un jeu
dadangereux. Il faut faire
atattention parce qu'il est le
prpremier ministre de tous les
ququébécois.
- - Exactement. De tous les
ananglophones aussi.
OnOn peut poser aussi des
ququestions de bonne foi n'impoe
ququel Québec.
- - On est sur une pente
glglissante. On est sur cette
pepente depuis la charte des
vavaleurs du gouvernement Maroi.
CeCe sont des questions
ididentitaires si on se souvien.
LeLe débat était tellement
popolarisant l'époque que le
didiscours dominant était vraimt
quque toute personne au Québec i
ététait contre l'achat des vales
c'c'était pas des bons québécoi.
CeCe n'est pas la vrai québécoi.
PoPourtantnt, il y avait des
frfrancophones dont Jacques
PaParizeau qui était contre.
MMême les mouvements souverains
s's'étaient très divisés sur cee
ququestion. Le discours dominant
ététait celui des bons québécois
sosont pour l'achat des valeurst
leles mauvais Québécois sont
cocontre. Il faut faire attenti.
SiSi on continue dans cette
didirection, le premier ministre
vava non seulement ont agonisé s
ananglophones qui sont contre
PePeut-être que Monsieur Legault
popourrait commencer à faire cee
didistinction. Il a ses positios
ilil est très populaire. Mais il
nene peut pas ignorer le fait qe
dadans la population, y compris
chchez les francophones, il y a
d'd'autres visions aussi qui
exexistent. Et qui ne sont pas
ananti québécois.
- - Conclusion. Il faut baissera
tetempérature un peu.
OnOn a l'impression qu'on ne
titiendra pas jusqu'à Noël.
- - On a eu les wokes, Maurice
DuDuplessis. C'est action
réréaction. On est dans
l'l'hostilité. C'est très
guguerrier.
- - C'est lié aussi à l'atmosphe
crcréée par la pandémie. Donc
j'j'espère que le premier minise
dudu Québec va comprendre qu'ily
a a quelque chose qui est arrivé
ququi n'était pas totalement
acacceptable pas et qu'il va
chchanger son attitude. On sort
d'd'une période où les vêtements
lalarges consensus sur lui.
IlIl ne faut pas qu'il cède à
cecela.
- - Merci beaucoup. Très apprécé
leles débats. Après la pause, ca
vava peut-être vous intéresser
paparce qu'il y a le nouveau Jas
BoBond qui sort. On a besoin
d'd'aller ailleurs. Apparemment,
c'c'est le meilleur des meilleu.
IlIls ont fait la synthèse et
c'c'est extraordinaire. Un Bond
totorturé et courageux qui court
apaprès ses démons.
C'C'est après la pause. Merci à
vovous trois.